hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about how to set up and perform a
scientific experiment whenever you are
designing a scientific experiment you
have to keep two different things in
mind that is what are your groups that
you are using in your experiment and
what are the variables in your
experiment first let's talk about the
groups two different groups and any good
experiment
the first one called the control group
is mainly used for the sake of
comparison that is comparing the two
different groups the other group and any
good scientific experiment is called
the experimental group and this is a
critical point the control group and the
experimental group differ by only one
variable if these two groups differ by
more than one variable then the
differences between the groups the
outcome of the experiment you won't know
which of the variables is contributing
to that difference that's why it's
important that these two groups only
differ by one variable also critical is
something that we know as sample size
sample size is the number of replicates
needed in each group and in any good
scientific experiment each group will
contain at least three replicates so for
example let's say that you were going to
conduct a scientific experiment
comparing two different groups of plants
and each of these groups needs to have a
minimum of three plants per group and
more than three plants is even better
but at least three the control group
might be three plants that are grown in
natural light the experimental group
might be three plants that are grown
only in purple wavelength light and
experiment like this you are comparing
the two groups to determine how the type
of light either natural light or purple
wavelength light how it affects the
growth of the plants now let that
experiment in mind let's talk about
different variables the first variable
to keep in mind is called the
independent variable the independent
variable is the thing that you the
researcher you the experimenter change
between these two groups so the thing
that you change in our example that's
the type of light either natural light
with the control group or the purple
wavelength light with the experimental
group now the next variable to keep in
mind is called the dependent variable
the dependent variable is the thing that
changes as a result of changing the
independent variable essentially the
dependent variable is the thing that
depends on whatever you have changed and
you can think of it as being what you
observe or what you measure
so for example in our experiment if the
independent variable is the type of
light natural light or purple wavelength
light then the dependent variable is
going to be the amount of plant growth
and you might be looking at a few
different metrics maybe you're looking
at how tall the plants grow how much
mass the plants gain over the period of
the experiment how many flowers or how
much fruit they produce these are all
different things that you could measure
and would be different dependent
variables now remember that with the
independent variable that is what is
differing between the groups and there
should be only one of those when you've
got these two groups the third type of
variable to keep in mind is called the
controlled variable now there are a few
different names for this the controlled
variable or the control variable or
sometimes just called the controls and
of course this can be a little confusing
you are also talking about a control
group that's why it's good to always
distinguish whether you're talking about
the control group or the control
variables now the control variables are
factors that critically are kept
constant so these are factors in the
experiment that are kept constant
between the two groups so that they
don't affect the results in our example
of different kinds of plant growth
conditions whether natural light for the
control group or purple wavelength light
for the experimental group the
controlled factors would be things like
the amount of water the type of soil the
length of experiment
ah the number of hours per day that the
plants were in either of the lighting
conditions so these are factors that are
kept constant that are the same for both
groups so that again the only difference
between those groups is the one variable
the thing that you change the
independent variable so that you can
measure what changes as a result that
being the dependent variable so these
are the various things to consider when
performing a scientific experiment if
you are interested in learning more
about this kind of process and
specifically learning more about what is
known as the scientific method then
please see my video on that topic but
this is it for today
thank you for watching and I hope you
learned a lot